I've heard many variations of
the story
about the cocaine bear.
The what bear?
Cocaine...
Yes, the cocaine bear.
That's a very interesting
story in itself.
One of the most fascinating
stories is the story
of Drew Thornton.
Thornton was a police officer.
He was an addict.
Addicted to adrenaline
and excitement.
People say he was as ludicrous
as ludicrous
could be.
He had about 70 pounds
of cocaine on him.
He had a James Bond
wristwatch that shot tear gas.
A lot of people noted
he was wearing Gucci loafers.
Well, this is very strange.
He developed one of the
biggest organizations
I've ever seen.
It has corruption, murder,
gun running, you name it.
Holy crap.
You would never
believe this happened.